prosecutors in Maryland said they are
dropping rape charges against two
teenagers who also are undocumented
immigrants the white house had used the
case to promote the president's
deportation policy but as chip Reid
reports the teens legal troubles are far
from over
it's horrendous and horrible and
disgusting what this young woman in
Rockville went through that was White
House spokesman Sean Spicer in March he
was commenting on a case at Rockville
High School in Maryland just outside
Washington in which two recent
immigrants from Central America aged 17
and 18 were charged with raping a 14
year-old girl in a school bathroom part
of the reason that the president has
made illegal immigration and crackdown
such a big deal is because of tragedies
like this the immigration pays its toll
on our people if it's done if it's not
done legally his remarks drew national
attention to the case and contributed to
a firestorm of anti-immigrant criticism
but the teenagers lawyers said the sex
was consensual and was even planned in
advance with the young girl today
state's attorney John McCarthy announced
the charges were being dropped we have
concluded that the facts in this case do
not support the original charges filed
in this matter
Maria Menna is the lawyer for the
17-year old this case blew up because
they immediately assumed they were
immigrants and as a result they
immediately assumed they were rapists
deputy press secretary Sarah Sanders
filling in today for Spicer was asked if
White House rhetoric about immigration
is encouraging people to jump to
conclusions against immigrants not at
all the president has been incredibly
outspoken against crime in any form
fashion both teens are still in custody
and they could be facing lengthy
deportation proceedings for CBS this
morning Saturday chip Reid Rockville
Maryland